So let's see how we can implement the lock
function. Our lock function needs to do something like this.
We need some sort of a magical lock that
works without using locks. That protects a critical section in
which we check if the lock variable is zero.
We put one in the lock variable. And we leave.
Because we have just successfully acquired the lock. If the
lock variable is one, we repeat all of this, and
we need to let others also be checking, so
really we need to insert the unlock magic here
and here. So basically we're just trying to do
this check. And if it's 0, setting to 1 automatically
with each other using some sort of magic. Obviously
there is no magic. So if there is no
magic, what to we do? There are several ways
to get the effect that lock magic would give us.
One way is to use what's called Lamport's Bakery
algorithm or some other algorithm that actually is able
to use normal old loading stored instructions to replace
lock magic, but these algorithms tends to be relatively
complicated. And just as simple a lock function will
take 10s of instructions to do. So doing this
is expensive, it makes the lock function slow. The
other option is to use some sort of special
atomic read and write instructions. So there will be
an instruction that does this check and set to 1,
or something similar to that, that would allow us
to in one instruction do this without needing the magic.